joining me today is a comedian actor and
podcaster Nick DiPaolo
welcome to the Reuben report thanks Dave
how are you I like that the first thing
you said to me was do I have to worry
about any language here yeah what you
want to drop it right now you want to
drop all your wealth your for your
beautiful like you said I've seen you on
YouTube and it looks like a TBC I felt
like I was walking to meet the press'
and yeah this is very professional yeah
well you got the you know I wore a
jacket for you though I was going to put
a tie on for you that would have been a
bit much yeah that's what I thought he
would have seen right through that does
anyone want to see a comedian in a tie
only if they're hanging themselves say
something wrong yeah I think that's
gonna be the theme of everything we're
doing here so for the people that don't
know you give me a little a little
background on Nick DiPaolo priest and up
priest and up did you have a life before
I don't know if you call it a life hi
I'm Emma had a heartbeat not breathing
yeah I grew up with about 22 miles north
of Boston and a very middle-class white
suburb pretty much and went to college a
university of maine and came out of
college took a job selling frozen steak
and seafood door-to-door on the back of
an Isuzu pickup truck that actually
seems like a good presently to stand up
it was a great play I've walked into
places that lay out all my stuff like
I'd go onto any any any residence small
businesses I'd go into a real estate
plan I'd lay out all my stuff if they
let me in and you know there could be 20
people firing questions how much is that
per pound but Bubba yeah it was great
I'd make them laugh and and you know
this stuff was really overpriced but it
was a boiler room operation and I'm sure
those people have seen me on TV since
you saying I'm gonna fly back I bought
haddock for 85 bucks a pound from that
jerk so ya did that for a few years and
then they took a job we haven't seen
those companies late at night that
market inventions if you have an idea
for it oh yeah I did that and started
where it meaning you did one of those
infomercials no I was I actually was a
Salesman like I had my own corner office
another boiler room operate
jeez which I didn't know when you come
out of college you'll take a legitimate
during a nice building not gonna suit on
and stuff they'd find out but but the
the biggest fun I took a job with the
winglet and rare coin galleries in
Boston it was like working at Merrill
Lynch it was on the 31st floor of a
skyscraper I had to wear a suit it
looked just like you know Charlie Sheen
a Wall Street when I went to work so I
did that for that was brutal I'm trying
to sell 50 thousand dollar coins over
the phone to somebody have never met
before
this is after selling steak and seafood
ordered last long right so I quit that
that that I I quit that and about a
month later I'm watching TV I see my
boss being let out by the by be like FBI
knows yes it was like a boil another
boiler room operation some of the coins
were fake and but uh but I started doing
stand-up you know write it right after
that probably a couple years out of
college and this is in Boston yeah in
Boston a place called stitches there's a
there's a documentary you probably stand
up stood up yeah and that little Club
were there interview people stitches
that's the first place I did my first
joke open mic yeah I was drunk at a
cookout in my parents house and like
good parents that gave me the keys and
said I want to try so yeah I put my name
in sure enough I get called I was a
Sunday night I pull up two stitches in
Boston and on the marquee I never forget
it says it said comedy hell that's what
so I that was my first George MacDonald
was the houses guy and bust and my first
line onstage was an ad-lib that's when
he said to me I know you're gonna be
funny I followed some guy in a tuxedo
and I had like a sweatshirt on and I
said I'm like I didn't know what to how
to dress and I said I didn't know I'll
be following my [ __ ] mr. Saunders
which is a local tuxedo place and that
got like a nice laugh and then I bought
the next four minutes yeah and I was
stupid enough to go back yeah so that's
pretty that's pretty much the beginning
of everybody right yeah you don't even
know how to screw up at the beginning
that's right so you're kind of good
by accident or something like that
that's right that must've been a magical
time in Boston I mean that's what the
documentary is about but there were
major major comics they're all doing it
seemingly for the right reason yeah more
before they even knew what what stand-up
could become yeah yeah and it's still to
this day you think about the people who
come out of Boston I mean you know Jay
Leno yeah
Conan Joe Rogan Louie Billy BER myself
even Kevin Meany and Janeane Garofalo
moved to Boston at the time yeah and
yeah it was a crazy Steven right he's a
yeah he's a legend yeah I mean so it's a
crazy but that was reminds me a
Goodfellas it was a glorious I had a
part of had a pot of coke next to my bed
at the how many condo it was it was
unblocked what's that how thin did you
cut the girl very thin would be that you
could do that metaphor there you could
do that at mix yeah you know exactly it
mix that's how they get paid in a comedy
club you could get paid and coke or
money in so there were a lot of drugs
yeah I wasn't a drug guy I played I was
a jock I played football in college and
and but they would kick me out of the
green room Steve sweetie and Gavin and
all the veterans okay Ricky you gonna do
this year to get out yeah
I'm standing out one time I tried it
John Pinette talked me into it after
about a year and a half he talked me
into doing a line I go up on stage at
Nick's I'll never forget it and I'm
talking about I have cottonmouth from
the club my lip keeps getting stuck like
this I have my hand in my pocket and at
one point it was quiet during this so
the guy yells out hey relax up there I
was jig jiggling my car keys all the
comics in the back went dying I kept I
kept tripping over my punchlines cuz my
mouth was my lip kept getting stuck on
my teeth that was how he didn't die
earlier I mean he's the only but I loved
him so much so I actually said I'll do
it right at you I don't mean any
disrespect to him but if he was doing a
lot of coke somehow the weight thing
didn't make snow snakes yeah which he
was pointed I'm cheeseburgers it you
know
I don't know but uh so that was the
beginning but following guys like Lenny
Clarke and Steve these guys the legends
that you your fans probably don't know
who they are but to this day I mean
Kenny Rogers and these guys are is good
now I've been doing 30 years later and I
still haven't seen anybody you know yeah
rock or room like that with a material
you know so what do you think happens to
that type of guy because I don't even
know those guys really like the guys
that don't make it cuz I know guy I mean
this is the same old story that we all
have but like some of the worst comics
that I started with right have become
successful on some of the best one and
most actually of the guys that I thought
were really great all right
completely disappeared and and we all
have that story well the guys embossed
and there's a couple reasons and it was
so big comedy stand-up was booming in
the mid 80s late 80s and that was the
mecca like you said but these guys like
Nick's comedy club held like 350 people
and it was just a money-making machine
and it was run by the boys and they had
like some of the guys signed agreement
saying they couldn't perform anywhere
else huh but they were making this is
back in the eighties they won but I
remember one of the guys time of the old
making 3 grand and 3500 a weekend geez
so why would you leave right in the
cities it's not like you even have to go
yeah you didn't have to go on the road
anyway in their homes and they you know
and like I said they party their ass off
and and and and they signed some of them
signed agreements ended they couldn't
perform elsewhere so that's what but I
mean they will make him killer money
didn't have to get on a plane
and and but but in the in the long run
was saying you know who are they but
Steve Sweeney's been in a few fairly
brother movies and and and Lenny Clarke
was brilliant I saw these guys that
they're Kevin Meany yeah that is I
always love Kevin meeting unbelievably
Swaney Meany night they call I was a
barback and at stitches comedy club
before I come that was the other job for
about six months I just wanted to be
near it you know and it was sweeney
meanie night it was Kevin Kevin meanie
and steve sweeney who was the Godfather
and of comedy and they would they would
yeah they had a show on Wednesday nights
Kevin meanie would go out on the street
with a cane
amaura live and the screen would come
down in the club so the audience could
watch mm-hmm and he would pull over
buses get on buses and stop making fun
of people on the him and Sweeney went
into a Chinese restaurant next door
Sweeney's got like a cutout of a cop
with his face throat he's pretending
he's like a food Chinese people clean up
the kitchen then they go into a ladies
room and and there's a woman in the
stove it kick open the door with a
camera Simplot picture crowd and it
would not fly these no wouldn't that's
not that would be too much fun and yeah
but picture that people inside what I've
never heard laughter like that my like
Kevin Kevin me he waved down a cop and
started giving the cops she and a cop
got at it you're watching this on a
screen inside yeah I mean brilliant
rainy and you know it was it was it was
a unbelievable time there's more stage
more stages available than comedians in
there I worked 300 nights my first year
and come visit what you're around 88 so
this is like sort of sort of at the end
of like the boom yeah boom right Isis
what do they say that wouldn't die
sold-out Madison Square Garden like
three nights in a row that was when the
whole thing shattered yeah yeah which I
think was around 90 or 91 yeah that
sounds about right
yeah but every I worked it's tough for
these guys to the game has changed so
much but me and louis c.k came up
together he was already doing it a year
or two before me I met him he was 18 I
was like 25 and but there every
restaurant he pub in New England is
Boston I could show you my book for my
first year Monday night I'd be a Chinese
restaurant Rhode Island Tuesday night to
be at some Mexican restaurant in
Franklin Mass Wednesday night I might do
a college Thursday night I'd be in
Nashville New Hampshire at a Holiday Inn
you know an honor seven nights a week
there was so much stage time as you know
as a stand-up there's nothing more
important yeah and we thought that's how
it was we didn't realize it was a boom
going yeah yeah we thought this is how
it is yeah so I quit my day job I was
making more money after about 10 months
I could handle a rough room I mean
that's pretty crazy after ten months all
right well I could handle I I could
handle
Frome and some of the rooms are rough
the one-nighter said I got the
reputation that I could close these
there was one Kingston and Kingston
massed down to the Cape and it was a
pool hall and hey let's go to have a
bucket of blood room hmm
and I went down and there's people
literally playing pool on the back while
our duel mice but by the end of it they
had put the pool sticks down and the guy
that ran the place said this he's the
first guy that ever had those guys Wow
amen and I got so I started to close
rooms after buddy Barry Katz was my
manager yeah hee hee hee hee booked
every room in New England so I had work
every night and you could make you know
I was making on the weekends I'd make
six seven hundred eight hundred dollars
in cash and I was you know making about
as much as I was during the day so I put
my day job that's crazy
for time right no 10-month comedian in
New York City if you make six hundred
bucks in a year even now I think you're
you're running thrilled right I feel I
feel bad for these younger yeah it's a
whole different game what do you make of
just sort of you know when people say
well comics are all just messed up and
and the whole thing what do you make
about the pain related to comedy that
drags all of us in there I think some of
its overblown I didn't you know I mean
we're all we all have a screw loose
somewhere yeah but this whole stuff that
you know oh you know it has to be the
kids who were bullied and I don't buy
that yeah even Bill Hicks had a bit
about that that he didn't buy into that
either importing his parents supported
him whatever he did blah blah blah which
is sort of the way I was I was very
quiet and serious as a kid at me too
yeah and I bullied as much as I was
blamed nobody likes to say that but it's
the truth that's the point yeah we bully
I've been bullied and I bullied Nick
we're losing a lot of social justice
warrior cred right now we're supposed to
be Nick riced know what I'm here for
man Bill Hicks I miss Bill Hicks I mean
he was a little before my time but like
like that that relentless pursuit of
truth in stand-up yeah and and he was
politically to the left but he was
really funny and hateful about it yeah I
mean it was he's a conviction that's
what I learned from watching him yeah
even to this day but I have a joke of my
head and I'm like I know if I should say
this or not I thought of him as a
barometer
yeah but you know he was on
left he wasn't getting too much trouble
yeah showbiz wise but he said some you
know stuff the way he's to talk about
rush limbaugh and stuff I do the same
thing to Nancy Pelosi yeah well he's a
little bit about Leno regardless the way
you think about Lindo I mean it's one of
the it's one of the it's so absolutely
perfect it's just perfection his head
blue peacock I mean come on Doc is that
a red jacket or that his brains on your
the angst and the I have a lot of that
in me I have that chip that he had for I
don't know about whatever reason I was
born like that you know yeah and and
that's what I love the bottom
politically you know he's to always say
there's nobody out there that could hurt
us when you know talking about I I RAC
or whatever right you know how we have
the biggest military they have the third
big whatever right there's nobody out
there there's a [ __ ] threat to us I'd
like to have bring them back to life ago
you know tell him about 9/11 yeah you
know yeah so but but he was so he was
what a writer and you know I don't have
to be on the same side of you
politically define you funny yeah that
but I find that do you find the left
doesn't do that yeah alright so let's
shift there a little bit what do you
think has happened to stand up in the
last say well now it seems like twenty
years but but in the last couple years
especially it's gone from where it was
seriously edgy wherever every morning I
wake up now and I'm like man I wish
George Carlin was still alive not only
because I think he was the greatest and
I've ever but we need still some of that
although he'd be getting booed off
college campuses because he's an old
white guy you know I love Carla yeah my
idols too but he he was a lefty and he
created this environment but he was more
I mean he was more I guess he was a
lefty but he was relentlessly against
political correct yes so yeah that shows
you have some kind of stuff has changed
but what do you make of sort of what's
happened I was telling you right before
we started the only reason I'm doing
stand-up now again is because so many of
these comics now have become the
politically correct children that
they're supposed to be making fun of and
I was like I guess I got to go do it
again and now I'm doing it again why
blame and I'm not kidding you the
feminist movement there at the core
there at the core of all this
politically correct or
shet that drives us nuts they they are
at the core of it the whole I think
society's been feminized we you know
guys and I get him generalizing here but
for the most part even Louis's
generalization will just cause yeah I
know that's why they want though they
want us to be walking around qualifying
every statement I don't mean everybody
know exactly yeah
that's one thing I do in my act I don't
try to balance it out
pile on and but but sensitivity pcs
bents is based on sensitivity
yeah and and and that's not in our DNA
late in most guys you know III and they
have a never their never-ending list of
grievances they just they can't leave
that alone
I don't watch movies anymore I stopped
about 20 years ago cuz I was aware of it
something made me aware of it I I can't
suspend my disbelief and watch Angelina
Jolie beat up ten Marines I can't
[ __ ] do it
you know I really can't yeah and III
just it's been feminized and and this
business draws a lot of people who were
bullied and [ __ ] even back in the in the
80s when I would watch films I go why is
and I would say this this is way before
I was in comedy yeah like oh why is the
bad kid at the high school always the
white kid with a leather jacket the jock
yeah and every and it's still just a
this was thirty years later back to the
future everything yeah this is this I
mean I know this that's just you know
there's a lot more woman comics and and
and whatever but the that's what the PC
comes from it comes from the left nobody
ever says that the census yeah I know
people have bought it what do
politicians on both sides yeah in guys
the back wait I guess this guy's fault
though we let it get this far
yeah is it weird how it flipped though
like cuz you could look at say the 90s
when the right was screaming about video
game violence and all this stuff and
it's like yeah no it doesn't cause real
violence if anything it actually uses so
this is where it's like to me the right
doesn't get a pass they the right is way
better now in terms of political
correctness and free speech yeah but but
yeah the left has become well yeah it's
one thing you yell about video game
violence what
which may or may not be true whatever I
never bought into that I watch The Three
Stooges from age 60 buddy I never [ __ ]
I have the crowbar my mother in the eyes
yeah but yeah they were wrong on some
stuff but but not to the degree that
your left's gone with changing the less
political correct is you know the
definition is you know changing people's
behavior through language and you know
with the today it's going the he and the
she you want to be called a and I'm
sorry that I didn't ask about your
pronouns before we started yes I'd like
to be I don't even know what thing I
call me them it it Clara so most people
come but so it was kind of funny do you
do you remember do you remember when it
started seeping into the club's not
right there's no one specific moment you
know I've been doing this 31 years or
whatever so I finally after all this
time people come out to see me they know
what's coming mmm-hmm you know but I do
remember early in my career I was a
Clark universe and Clark universe I
think it's Clark in Massachusetts even
liberal from Massachusetts ago
that's liberal yeah and I did some joke
about a middle east and got a gas
station he couldn't find my oil he was
trying to chant I said I had the one
middle-aged and guy that couldn't find
or whatever and some kid in the front
row good college he's got sure he goes
Jesus that was a what are you gonna do
abortion joke snacks so I just rattled
off like eight abortion joke at the top
of my head and the whole place is bored
yeah
and it's the only time I got off stage a
couple minutes early really yeah so that
and that was a long time ago yeah but I
don't know if you say it with enough
conviction I don't know I get a thrill
out of it these are good and bad times
but I've always even after my first open
mic about six months in my open mic
experiencing a comic said to me you're
politically incorrect that's that's
where it's headed and even I said to him
I go I go it's gonna get a lot worse
that was this was like an 88 or 89 yeah
and it did get a lot worse do you
can get much worse than no and I mean
now you see articles in BuzzFeed every
day about stand-up guy there needs to be
not funny now we should enter you know
did you see that article I did see we
should enter a phase where stand-up
shouldn't be funny so that we could have
conversation
yeah or even having that clown would say
stand up that's the entities of one city
and it supposed to be yeah you're
supposed to say what people won't say
and and that's in the DNA of a comic I
mean in high school if I saw an opening
in class for a joke now you know let it
fly and I can't believe it's to this
point but I don't know where else you
can go well I can go in the direction
that you know they'll force clubs to
stop booking people and they'll kick the
rest of us off well it was until a black
market will pop up like anything else
when you prohibit something right yeah
and then I get really good fun can we
have the goddamn war I'm on the side
with all the guns here we go right there
I'm on the side of holy guns ok let's
get it on I am tired of it man but at
least I get set by now at least i market
myself and people know thanks to my
podcast and and after 30 is a stand-up I
was never I always I said stuff on tough
crowd
yeah III called we showed a commercial
and I said that's cultured the cultural
Marxist some people who write this [ __ ]
never eat sick what's he talking
I got like pigeon hole that day right
you know that was got to be at least 10
years ago so that's before at least 10
years ago I was reading a lot of pep you
can and who I still love okay what are
you so you were in the tough crowd crew
yes Colin Quinn obviously and that whole
crew that show it was only on for a
couple years actually but it probably
would never well not probably you would
never make it on Comedy Central now oh
god no you know they actually said to
Colin who's a genius Colin grew up in if
you know you know yeah I'm he's the
sweetest guy as bright a guy as you'll
ever meet he grew up in Brooklyn and you
know I went to high school black kids
Puerto Ricans Dominican he knows that
world yeah and they actually said them
after a few episode a tough crowd after
or a couple seasons they said what he
let leave the race stuff to ship hell he
meant saying that the Carlin
that's actually racist I mean that of
course it is yeah of course it is
people love that chokes me and Patrice
yeah me and Patrice would unload on each
other and people loved me for I was on a
plane in Atlanta right after me and
Patrice had a good toe to toe on the
show and I was a plane in Atlanta and I
see this black guy look at me with his
son yeah I'm getting a little nervous
and they come up to me and and they go
we love you man on tough crowd
yeah and anja is like you know people
once you meet people face to face that's
what sort of because you clearly have a
good disposition especially for a comic
is that partly what it is like I see
this now after being on tour for the
last year if I go online it's just like
an endless hate fest of lunacy
everyone's trying to destroy each other
yeah and then every night when I'm
touring and I do meet and greets after
the show and I want all of these people
and nobody cares what sex they are right
sexuality or rouler and everyone's great
so I feel like I live in these alternate
worlds where the real world happens to
be pretty damn good it is and it's not
just social media just it just the
mainstream media I'll be laying there
watching TV and I'll send a PSA oh come
on for bullying Jesus Christ leave it
alone for fiber I can't watch a Red Sox
game I'm from Boston New England Sports
Network is the most PC I love my Red Sox
I I have trouble there's always a oh you
got 12 women from the Maine woman
shelter here this kids would cancer it's
like Jesus I go to I'm watching this to
get away from that yeah well look what
happened ESPN I mean they've destroyed
themselves in the name of being woke and
they didn't give a [ __ ] today
hey do they have that much money or
that's Disney nothing is more PC than
Disney yeah they're at the core of it oh
so wait you mentioned well get we'll get
there but I don't want to jump over
Patrice because you've watched a couple
of your core guys died let's do this
would you know so greg Giraldo young was
like on his way to becoming starves
scars I used to live like two or three
blocks away from him on the other West
and I remember seeing him I would see
him all the time he'd have his two kids
and if he walking them to school or
whatever and I used to see him at
Equinox at the gym and he he was fit and
he seemed like he was like I used to
look at him and be like we didn't really
knew I was a comic but we didn't know
each other but I would look at him and
I'd be like oh you're a comic who like
became a human you you actually became
like a real person too and I thought of
I sort of wanted to emulate that in a
way and I remember I saw him at the gym
one day and he's pumping blah blah blah
he was dead two days later and I like it
really threw me for a loop even though I
didn't know the guy that well yeah
you've had a couple guys in your crew
that just yeah
Patrice inand and and Greg even now when
I hear him on the radio you know if he
listened to satellite and and I'm like I
got a good line from a tree a grass and
it just it I know never really got over
the Jarawa
just shocked me when that happened he
seemed too smart I'm he's a Harvard guy
yeah law guy but that's what I loved
about him he gave Lent some credibility
to stand up I mean a very bright kid and
always yeah he was always jovial and and
you know and he would pick migraine he
would watch me when I was a little ahead
of him yeah and he would be all asking
all the right questions you know about
stand-up and and and he was on his way
you know like you said and Patrice I
just love Patrice because he's a Boston
guy he's a curmudgeon and didn't her
didn't hide his dislike for whitey yeah
I didn't I might dislike for hambo
friends which that's why we liked each
other yeah you know I mean and and what
a blow to lose those it's always the
good ones isn't it yeah only the good
day you know Sarah Silverman ellipses
and Robby Patton Oswald and Kathy
Griffin oh well now you're talking about
the people that dragged me back in I
mean those three particularly actually
but there's a couple of others that
these are the ones that are talking
about we can't let Milo's book be
published it doesn't matter what you
think about Milo comedians talking about
banning books I mean can you imagine
says that about whoever you know Bill
Maher should not be able to write a book
yeah I mean yeah I mean they are artists
and they a for groupthink yeah which is
the quickest way to stifle any creative
their little fascist [ __ ] I hate him I
tried to be nice I actually text a
patent Oz well I don't know him that
well yeah when his wife died I felt so
horrible I tax him a couple times and
then I
read this stuff know that he says
tonight I'm like I don't like this guy
wish it was him just busting balls girl
yeah but you know me and Sarah Silverman
who was she
yeah well couldn't follow me at my worst
night yeah there it is so so what do we
do to break that thing because it does
still seem to be spreading like I get
that there's some there there's some
push back now and there well first off
do you what do you consider your
conservative I mean if I know I know it
doesn't really matter and no I know but
I I'm like in quinces Colin Quinn so
this - I don't know I got labeled that
out - tough crowd yeah but we're in show
business right okay I guess something
this is show business yeah and in
Hollywood or wherever and showbiz if you
if you're out of 20 issues if you lean
right on two of them you're not you're
not yeah so I kept getting pegged with
that conservative conservative but I'm
really not I'm for the truth I call them
as I see them yeah and I'm sure you know
conservatives back in the civil rights
were on the wrong side of that not now
these guys of them they're on the wrong
side to me yeah anytime you want to
censor but yeah I mean I'm Pro gay
marriage I don't really care about guns
I can't say I'm pro-life only because
like I have a dad dying of Alzheimer's
right now and if I could put him out of
his misery tomorrow I would and when I
was young I I was glad that was Planned
Parenthood round I got in trouble with a
few girls or whatever so I'd be a
hypocrite to say yeah but this way to me
abortions I'll go with that
I mean this is ridiculous what's going
on yeah you think it's strange look at
those positions which I'm with you I
describe myself I'm a grudgingly Prout
really exactly I wish I didn't have to
be yet but I'd worry you know but I know
I know several women that have had
abortions in the last yeah just I don't
think I could take that away from them
but I completely get the pro-life side
right even to take those positions you
just said if you're gonna take anything
that's not on the progressive side
you're one of a bad guy yes well that's
what it is you have to check off all the
boxes yeah well your ear and Nazi or
whatever which is
and that this whole you're a bigot who
do you who do you think you are you can
label somebody that that that is to me I
believe you've never had a racist
thought or I might at a racist that
those are don't people have the right to
call me a bigger and that person doesn't
exist
hmm I mean the sanctimony on it is I
can't believe it yeah my and I buddy
Pete Bogosian who's been on the show
many times calls this thing a secular
religion and that's what it is become a
really Jets what it is these people yeah
yeah
they put it before anything okay I know
we got our work cut out for us huh the
solution is a war folk Center I mean
we're all we're gonna balkanize and
break apart or whatever and whatever
well you know it's funny you say that
but I do see this undercurrent of people
talking about that now do you actually
think yeah that that's where we ended
that's right ventually over years these
ideas just keep percolating everyone
realizes how much they have in
disagreement with their neighbor and
then we end up in some horrible place I
mean it's pretty much everything I've
been fighting against I've been trying
to get these sides didn't get more
decent but but I get the impulse on that
for the gaps too big now there is no
middle ground there is no dissenting I I
use an analogy it's like an athlete's
knee and think of Bobby you are smite
it's like you know the cartilage is gone
yeah yeah you know I mean this uh yeah I
mean width is such a gap we're seeing
the world from two different lenses yeah
I don't see that closing I only seen you
know and and social media sort of
through the gas on it and expedited it
what do you make about what's going on
with the with the tech companies and
censorship and all that because that
also is another thing that should be
right in a comedians wheelhouse and I
don't see these guys doing it I see Seth
MacFarlane telling you know saying the
family guy's not gonna do gay jokes
anymore
The Simpsons isn't gonna put a poo in
episodes the hardest-working guy on the
show who is completely welcomed who is
an immigrant that changed homers stance
and illegal immigration and if you kill
you and other things in this country
in Hinduism and veganism horrible a
horrible I'm off the TV just disgusting
yeah but all of this it's all related to
social media the way everyone just we
can look at the past and immediately
erase it and we're automatically gonna
be better and all of this endless
[ __ ] what do you have all that well
the tech companies have it out for us
are you starting that thing with Jordan
we're working
yeah oh yeah yeah and you know and they
had their looked at they've been fair to
me but I you know I don't want to
contribute to it yeah I don't know where
their money's going yeah you're in we'll
have to discuss the rest of it not with
the cameras yeah of course
yeah leave it to me to bring them yeah
that's right though well even just
related to that you know I saw one guy
it's like a fairly well-known you know
verified blue check lefty attacking me
and Jordan over leaving because you know
Karl Benjamin sargon of akkad said the
n-word and he said it and the guy kept
saying if he had said it with an A at
the end instead of an R at the end it
would have been okay and I thought you
guys density serious because then it
would have been sort of an endearing or
at least a colloquial way of saying it
right he said it with a hard R even
though with the way he said it was
against the alt-right anyway but putting
aside reality for a second but I thought
the way you people whittle down
everything it's not even about a word
it's about the intonation that you say
the word it's like think about that yeah
just that alone and if you've never said
anything right you've never said it one
way or the other row exactly I corrected
myself you know yeah I mean that proof
so silly their arguments are yeah but
but I love that clip Louie that
governors that clip that surfaced a
couple weeks ago yeah so what do you
make of that so you and you and Louie go
way back obviously everyone knows what
what happened with him give me the sort
of look I've said it a million times I
he did that to my sister I would have
punched him in the face or a front you
know a girlfriend or whatever
obviously there was horrible behavior on
his part yeah but I mean capital offense
right growing his life and career get
over yourselves ladies you know I lived
with him I'd do a joke onstage about it
I let's you have to let's tip right
between him and Harvey Weinstein I mean
everybody's being lumped in now yeah
yeah and yeah what Louie did was
horrible and stuff but I you know then I
do a bit of but it said live with him
for a year and a half I saw his dick
maybe ten times four times essential so
I love them he's he's a great father
he's he's as smart a guy as I ever met
and and he was all I love them he was
always a little reckless yeah and and
you making that thing I mean it gets to
where I've talked about earlier or what
we talked about earlier about just
comedians and sort of being messed up
and whatever like that thing about like
he's got everything right I mean that
that PayPal shot when he had that
million bucks just sitting in there cuz
he sold his special just like that like
but yeah everything he was respected by
everybody like and yet some other [ __ ]
still gone down he and I think were we
all suffer from that at some level like
it's just it's part of the human
condition yes
yeah we're we're humans we're flawed he
never Louis never cared about money even
even when he started to make at the
beginning and I was like his big brother
he he'd even had a handle money when
when we were you know when we first met
would we went to San Francisco we're
doing a punch line me and him were like
co-headlining something he goes I'm
going out to rent the VCR this is back
in the early 90s so he can watch movies
at the hotel whatever yeah
and we both had literally I'd probably
probably $900 net worth between he comes
back with a $600 trumpet that he bought
this is how we explain to him the you
know the value of money and I still
don't think that's not what drives him I
know he got all the success commercially
and all the money and stuff yeah but he
said he's the most interesting person
yeah I've ever met it so what do you
think you think he's doing the
forgiveness machine right I love what he
basically waited one back and waited
around and he saw the bitching and we
stuck his face out for two minutes and
people going wild me know when he's out
the club before you kill babies yeah
what do you what the [ __ ] is going on
here so he stuck his face out took the
temperature of it was a bunch of whining
and stuff and he probably thought about
mild it over a few months that [ __ ] this
I'm coming back yeah and I'm throwing
haymakers I love the way all the stuff
all the
that you know before this that loved him
now he's there - it's a comment yeah but
it goes back to that feminist stuff it
always goes back to that you know so he
get he gets back in and then of course
all the articles were now he's all right
you saw all that you know yeah he's
gonna be the king of the red states yeah
that's my I've been working out of 30
years oh yeah he was wet my dick out and
I could um yeah and he won't be and he
know his Carmody will be like it's
always been
yeah I don't think he will be the you
know but but but I do have a problem
with a few comics out there who are kind
of famous who are now getting the label
is a you know edgy and antique piece see
who's edgy that you think it's actually
edgy these days me my whole career we
should do a show together we should do
yeah we should yeah alright we'll do
something edgy is edgy is doing jokes
pushing Rachel over the table a black
people right there well you could get
punched in the fit that's edgy not going
and finding a patent Oz well going in
front of the files of nerds and then
that's not edgy it never was you know me
telling Mike how I feel about women
certain well you know although the
feminist movement yeah and doing stuff
that could hurt you I've been doing my
whole but you got to be funny about it
first right for these day you have his
lettering otherwise you end up preaching
and and like Billy burr is good
now he's getting labeled as kind of edgy
but Billy's been a very liberal guy and
to me his politics of the past helped
create this environment I love when they
call him racist I was just at a wedding
with him a couple of weeks ago his white
this black you eating I know I love his
wife and he Billy is the least racist
person I know can you imagine but but
those guys you know I was pushing that a
long time ago and and and and and now be
like gays you know real and not Billy
saw but burr right now to me is the
funniest he's like every guy I grew up
with in Boston mm-hmm just he sounds
like every kid I grew up with and
brutally funny but my point being those
I
Bill Maher was getting all remember Bill
Maher went after his own audience
because of a Muslim thing and stuff yeah
but but I said good for bill but Bill
you helped create this environment I
know I'm so like with him cuz I loved
him for so many years he was like my guy
he was the right kind of liberal free
speech liberal yeah I loved him and I've
always wanted to be on the show and I
want to do this with him I really do but
but these last couple years even though
I think he's still on the right side on
the free speech stuff yeah but when he
apologized because of the n-word
the iced tea or whoever it was it was
like this is bad this is bad and now his
Trump stuff has gotten so he's like he's
become like a character of caricature
himself and I and I say that with like
the most respect like I want you to be
better again or something you know yeah
but what does that tell you about just
sort of the way television also has
changed because you've been on The
Tonight Show you've been on Letterman
you've been on all the late-night yeah
they seem completely irrelevant to me
now I mean that I'm not putting you down
you know just like the Machine has now
changed they said that when Jay was this
yeah and I love Jimmy - I love Fallon -
but it's a whole different and and my
stuff I mean I wasn't you know when we
start comedy at the beginning you create
try to have a lot of kind of TV clean
because you want to get some exposure
yeah so I wasn't super edgy but on my
first letter and I did mention like a
gay woman arguing with me about her dog
or whatever yeah whatever you know I
guess compared to what other people that
I made fun of homeless my opening line
right or whatever so I guess that was
kind to edge that could at least work
then now you're not getting on The
Tonight Show with that well it's funny
you know I went to see my buddy Joel s
when he did his first let him and and
the girl said that they wanted me to
come back on it was like a casual chat
in the greenroom but she goes you can't
do any cancer stuff any home she starts
listing and I got mall set yeah as much
as I would I would have loved to dumb
now you know one more Letterman her we
all should have seen this what's that
line from the comedian documentary that
Seinfeld did when orny Adams says he
goes on The Tonight Show and they made
him change you know there's one person
on this bus and that person has lupus or
something and that was his joke because
he was the only person on the bus but
they made him change it from lupus oh
yeah her dystrophy yeah yeah
the other way like the weaving it works
like someone they had a debate like a
network executive at a debate like which
is more offensive lupus or muscular
dystrophy I'm honestly not even sure
which way it was which tells you how
stupid is but what do you think about
that just the way that it's like the old
days the old days like you know you
wanted to get on Carson so you could do
your five and maybe he invites you to
sit down and if he does right now you're
a star that's just Oh God
that's been gone forever no I was
excited because Jay Jay Leno was one of
my influences people laugh when I say I
go go watch Jay Leno when he used to
appear on the Letterman Show in the 80s
Jay would have him on three times a
month yeah and Jay was the king of
stand-up at that point he would go on
there
gooble I still go home and I go girly
sometimes watch Jay as a guest how funny
he was yeah that's what really pushed me
Jay I grew up about 10 minutes from Jay
he I go this guy looks like me sounds
like me he's Italian Scottish should go
and in sarcastic and so that was one of
my influences and and but the whole game
has changed
yeah do you think it matters anymore
that like there was a certain there was
a certain magic to this idea that you
could go through that machine there was
like an actual path to be and success
yeah that's all gone do you do you think
do you miss it at all or the idea that I
like the kind of a free-for-all I like
it now yeah I like that we're all doing
our own thing yeah and I can't ascend
not used as the model at Kennison was so
offensive and stuff yeah but he became
it came such a cult had such a cult
following then Hollywood came to him
yeah once you get so big you know you
have so many followers and stuff
Kennison sort of did that he made
Hollywood come to him he was outrageous
and they finally put him on Letterman
stuff I like what's going on like as far
as me on my podcast being able to cut
loose and people are looking for you and
I guys like you and I know yeah this is
very few I did a gig Friday night in San
Diego the comedy palace I was in San
Diego Friday night where are you really
yeah I haven't done that but I well I
was at the Balboa theater with Peters
and so that's a
that's a different thing you should have
come to the comedy I pull up and like
God it's kind of a wrestler but I go in
the beautiful comedy room set up
perfectly yeah probably 150 people maybe
yeah
but San Diego a sweet spot for guys it
was a 60% Latino mm-hmm and they loved
me I thought no this is what this is
when you feel great about penis like a
Mexican one in the front she had to be
65 years old yeah she goes to me after
the show say hi to the twinks those are
my two producers of my part yeah she
loved my podcast she's like a 65 year
old Mexican one yeah when I was doing
the religious stuff she was hanging on
every word and then it was all these
biracial couples a white guy with a
Mexican why evil or you know vice versa
and and then some white military guys
and they wanted to hear me I'm doing I'm
gonna get real political I'm not a real
when you come to see me now it's a mix
yeah but my next album is gonna be all
pugs I was waiting to hear for they were
they perk up when I go into the
political stir yeah well there's
definitely a need for this type of
political things you end up which is
what I'm doing but that's I was gonna
ask you do you even consider yourself
political per se no yeah so I kind of
bizarre right Colin Quinn and I've used
this at every interview I've ever done
Colin Quinn said at 20 he goes 20 years
ago and I said I'm not really political
comic-con not really conserve he goes
Nick but he goes his type of guy you
could be you could be telling the
McDonald's joke open tell how you voted
that sums it up I go after the macro
it's more cultural with me you know yeah
I don't go up there and talk about the
farm bill that was you know that went in
the toilet yeah I'm more macro I I
always push the racial stuff because to
me that's the that's the one issue that
is the biggest gap between how it's
discussed privately as opposed to
publicly they're the biggest lie and the
meat I can't watch another home alarm
commercial with the five criminals away
yeah I said that 20 years ago I've been
called the I started the whole look at
the dumb white father in the commercial
on my first album in 1994 I said it I
think I was listening to rush at the
time right you know and he sort of made
me aware
yeah but I watch these commercials and
it's it's just hilarious but it's weird
how everything's become political right
like it did yes
see I I was always doing political stuff
I was a political science major so I was
always yeah but but actually I I'm so
less interested in politics more so now
than I've ever been
I like the cultural thing yeah what
we're talking about here is called -
yeah that's for article per se right but
it's weird that everything is politics
now our celebrities our politics every
we're always talking at the screws are
political Sports Center is political
it's kind of gross actually yeah it was
such a media driven Society and now
these social media has added another
layer but it's gross it's all said we
don't have lives outside of you know you
got to do the detox I get off on the
weekends and I take August no phone no
nothing all of August all of August no
no talk try to avoid CNN while you're
you can't it's only taking a helicopter
what I can't go to an airport I can't go
to the gym I can't go to the burger
joint little bit just going to the gym I
have to walk around like this but I but
I did it because like I I think you've
got to escape some of this lunacy oh you
having to run again I and I don't even
realize it but yeah like I accidentally
put on a movie the other night
that's like Rocky free however you know
nothing but it felt so good that she
felt like I was eating cotton candy or
something yeah as opposed to oh it's but
just watch this I'm here and then flip
it over yeah you're right yeah I mean
and actually Jo list is comic young
comics said that to me a couple years
ago because you watch too much news I go
I have to defend myself from [ __ ]
like you but so how do we how do we push
back against the mob that that seems to
be the big thing now it's like I
actually think there's some momentum
there I think we're waking up a certain
event we are waking up but here's the
problem Dave what we're watching now is
a plan that the left put together 50
years ago infiltrating schools and all
the institutions taken over you know
Hollywood and it's all comic different
that's why they're winning mm-hmm I
don't think we will be able to you know
I mean it'll take 40 years to
we have to grab back the institutions
that you know entertainment and and and
so what does that mean I mean well I
guess we're doing alright when it will
be able be done that's the price I am
unless again unless it comes to violence
I
but yeah it's gonna take forever all's
we have we don't all we have is Fox News
you know Fox we the only ones that put
me on they're the only ones I can give
my liberal credit left and right I can't
get a call from the other ones I have an
interesting history well you can't
you're a conservative yeah and I don't
know conservative I'm actually a liberal
but there's no I'm a real liberal
there's no right right there's none of
us left anymore that's what Louie is
yeah look Louie couldn't be more fair
you know when we used to argue race and
Paul even when I did is his show on FX
you know Horace and Pete he you know he
wrote my book and I would he would let
me look at it first you know and he look
he's an old-school liberal looks at both
sides very thoughtful about it but isn't
that the irony with with what's happened
to the comics is that most comics
inherently I think are libertarians most
comics want to say whatever they want
and live however you want enough and I'm
gonna live however I want but they've
been like brainwash they've been like
yeah I realized it's even worse they've
been just infected yes by this thing
that I guess I guess it will in the
short term give them some success or
something so it's easy to do it you know
and what's creeping me out it seeped
into management now like people who run
the clubs yeah that's what creeps me out
you know that is that happening I
haven't heard stories like Kurt Metzger
get in trouble for doing a rape joke
yeah they said that all but don't tell
him why and and Bobby Slayton going
after you know Joe Carr on some black
woman in the crowd she got offended and
now the helium that's what he used to
him how couldn't you love Bob Slater I
mean and I mean where we don rickles be
right now you know and that was he did
it for all the right reasons every
ethnic joke was for the right reasons
because we're all equal in this country
you freaks he when he was on a lot about
a few years ago one of his last
appearances that was probably going on
ten years ago they were - they had a
camera in a bar next
in the lobby to black all the black
women at the bar or whatever and Rickles
is all good hey
oh and they're looking around at the
camp you know what are you drinking in
that moonshine what I'm very married
whatever Ripple and all these I'm going
home even me I'm sitting home going you
know and they still don't know with a
Cameron and you hear Rickles goes and
they wonder why they can't get any work
even the crown eleven thing that you
don't eat it to everybody everybody
across the board yeah not that not that
you have to that's my role to I don't
feel I need to be balanced because when
I sit home and I watch how white men
have betrayed and commercials and on TV
and in movies
I feel no need to balance it out you
have to show up people go why do you
make fun of white people I go go home
and watch TV
yeah well it does seem like it's
coordinated what's going on this endless
thing it's such of straight white men
and that you're that politicians are
doing it constantly that it's about
white men it's like you are racist you
people who call everyone racist you are
racist Congrats oh yeah you can
generalize now about white guys yeah I
mean I've been hearing that phrase for
ever typical typical frat boy you know
that's code for white yeah yeah you said
it's coordinated it really is isn't it I
mean this is where it's I say conspiracy
Colin quick is because it's not a
conspiracy it's so big that it's not a
conspiracy that's his theory it's not
that it's not infiltrated me and
academia they don't even have the cornea
and I'm like no I still think there's
ten guys in a room so that's uh it
depends how far you want to go yeah yeah
naturally nice and I don't know what the
other bora yeah but it does feel like an
agenda because they follow a certain
every commercial has that certain you
know yeah that progressed there's a
progressive commercials would you ask
Gillette you must have loved that one oh
my I couldn't believe it
that's Gillette as in Robert Kraft there
owns a Patriots right
yeah I actually Sam up you know I'm I'm
a die-hard Pats yeah like I don't even
know if I'm gonna watch a Superbowl look
I didn't mean it but uh it infuriated
yeah but how about the progressive
commercials George Soros that's one of
his companies by the way massive auto
insurer
those are the worst as far as
emasculating white guys especially the
the the latest one they the guy he said
I
he's got like a Members Only jacket on
and he's got a black buddy and they're
going out and the black guys have bills
my best friend but he's really changed
and he's he's handing out directions to
the club you know but he printed out and
and and you know can we get some gel a
panel poppers please and he's get khakis
on and he's playing you know a guitar on
the dance floor just dis just the I mean
it doesn't even bother me anymore
because I started picking these things
out years ago but this one it is brutal
you money it would be like having a
black guy tap-dancing right and fried
chicken in a commercial that you know
that offensive and the movie I just
watched that movie green book oh I
didn't see it huh try to watch that one
yeah especially if you're Italian you
talk about offensive oh my god yeah oh
my god is it a town I can't believe we
don't we Italians have a sense we have a
sense they literally have an Italian guy
in a wife-beater fold the whole pizza
yeah and eat it and then the black guy
in the movie doesn't even had to eat
fried chicken he had never had fried
chickens this stuffy right raised you
know well remember he doesn't how to
hold it like a guy at a commercial and
infomercials I was going to use a carrot
peeler is this happened to you I mean
it's propaganda data remember when when
Anthony sky our Moochie had to step down
after you know yeah two days as Tom's
director but every joke was about him
being Italian and in the month and I
didn't see Italians rioting no screaming
and it was just saying no we did all
right you know yeah that's why we can
take it but it just this kept this movie
it's why I don't go the movies and it
was so predictable
I should Brewer on the ending for
everybody but uh I don't know I've never
had probably checking before and he's
dead and then the Italian guy is just
like they projected everything like
black stereotypical behavior on him his
character it was just a reverse of roles
they sat down I literally did cross
referencing it looked like yeah you know
I mean you ever get worried that you
just even though you said it's
infiltrating the clubs that like manage
the rest of Hollywood think you're just
not going to get other gigs or will be
passing up Hollywood yeah
I've given up on Hollywood a long time
ago
I'll always uh you know stand up this is
always gonna be a place even when they
trying to shut down speech it's gonna
make it better for guys like us I think
yeah and in the long run but yeah I've
given up on that yeah I like you know I
mean if somebody wants to throw me in a
film or whatever I told my age and I go
up the breakdown doesn't say Nick Nick
DiPaolo type I don't want to do it
pretty cocky but thank up a stand-up in
the internet podcast yeah you think
we're gonna be better off in a couple
years or not you think I mean that
that's where we're at right like when
you say better off as a nation are you
an eyes well I mean just generally like
just this look if we let's pretend the
Civil War doesn't comment in five years
where do you think we're at we're on the
brink of Civil War where else we can go
that there's one side that doesn't want
to play it's one side it has no you know
you can't keep calling people bigots
people will go out and work and bust
their ass blue-collar people that make
this country great sound quantity but
they do and you're gonna keep pointing
your finger and call them racists and
bigots and and take more they confiscate
their money Ocasio Cortez and her stupid
plan yeah good 34 percent if you live in
New York City and you're over making
over ten million yeah and it's like yeah
we don't love to make ten million
doesn't mean the government gets to take
it just cuz they want no that's
confiscation but she's moral she said
it's moral that's how they do it if
you're immoral right if you're immoral
they can call you whatever you want
that's the whole Nazi you know it
Trump's a knife he's it not so you can
kill him if you really believe that
right that's what they do that's what
gets me the most that sanctimony yeah on
the left of oh they're just doing all
the [ __ ] that they're claiming everyone
else is projecting on us it's like
imagine what it'll be like if these guys
have the political power and the tech
power well you're gonna do it all the
20/20
well that's the thing they're gonna do
all of the things that they say Trump is
doing but no
he's in jail over free speech right now
no you know it's like once my biggest
fear yeah that they have they have
labeled Trump you know I mean just
relentless on this guy and they create
chaos mm-hmm and people eventually gonna
get tired of the chaos even if you like
Trump that's what I think
their plan was the left just constant
chaos with this guy accuse him of
everything and eventually even the
people in the middle of my god we have
to this is tiring right have to even
though I love what he's done I love how
he's exposed the swamp I really you know
I didn't like him as an entertainer and
stuff a lot of imprint I never watched
any of that garbage I loved him for what
he's done to expose these liberal
fascists and their crazy idea you can
almost get them to make take any
position now too because if Trump says
anything they're automatically against
it so when he's anti-war they're pro war
I mean it's actually an unbelievable
item yeah it's like we're scaling back
wars and now they're for more war in
Syria you're for staying in Afghanistan
like what the hell is going on here I
know you were the anti-war progress we
know they so blinded and again and
nobody mentions this everybody's way so
why do they hate him so much I go
because he's an alpha male blond-haired
blue-eyed billionaire that's why nobody
brings that up he embodies the devil for
them an older white guy billionaire yeah
you know alpha male who great you know
says he likes to grab women's boys
that's that's evil to them all that is
evil nobody ever brings up why you know
they always dance around this yeah shows
on Fox and I'm trying to think what
you're gonna get in the most [ __ ] for in
the last hour well I'm gonna watch where
you're gonna get her the most [ __ ] for
it for the last hour what do you mean
just as you said Aryan it's grabbing by
the [ __ ] it's like you know because
there's always people waiting yeah to
you know watch something for an hour and
find the ten seconds that they can grab
them and edit it yeah
I don't give a [ __ ] yeah yeah that's all
he can't hurt me anymore but that's not
why I love him cuz he said that I'm just
saying yeah yeah no no I got you I got
you we have that in the back of my head
you know oh absolutely no I don't like
right before I do an interview I go yeah
this is how it's gonna go
what how they gonna hurt me are they
gonna kick me off my own podcaster it's
not like I'm on an ABC sitcom or right
well they could start going for servers
and you know try to bump everybody off
all of these social media sites I mean
that isn't perhaps there's some people
working on a solution to that if you
know what I mean I heard that I'm
praying that it's true I'm in the middle
of reading his book right now that guy
that guy and he's brilliant in the I was
I get from the book is you're supposed
to do the right thing who wants to look
that way that's very boring yeah it's
better than the alternative right but
you know yeah yeah I hope that comes to
fruition
all right well all right let's uh let's
do a gig together absolutely yeah please
yeah all right we're gonna make you
happen all right cool everybody can
follow Nick can I sell them to your
Twitter send him to Nick dip [ __ ]
abduction that's not my show the Nick
DiPaolo show it's it's free on Monday
and Wednesday it streams on YouTube and
Facebook live at a few other places and
then Tuesday and Thursday it's a patreon
but you could do it all at my website
and we made it so simple because I'm not
a tech ie that yeah but Nick dip calm
and that's where you go and come see me
live because it's still my bread and
butter
Nick dip calm and don't forget to try
the veal
[Music]